[Music]
this is a really interesting question
which is what are the ramifications of
the college education system potentially
and we believe in a bubble that's likely
to burst and is already bursting and
with parents and employers looking to
find alternative ways to get their
people their kids or their students the
skills they need to be able to be
successful citizens and successful in
business so what was interesting about
the education system is everything in
the education system was designed to
support the existing system like most
businesses designed to serve the
publisher the professor the
administrator all the people that worked
at the school but you looked at the
student you said they're forced to live
in a dorm they don't want to live in pay
a price they don't want to pay they're
forced to use a cafeteria the first year
or so because it's in the best interest
of the school not the student they have
to pay a fortune for books that they
don't want to buy in subjects they don't
want to take you just think of all the
things you go to ATM on college campuses
that kid takes out ten bucks they pay
350 as a fee and so we realized very
quickly that the biggest problem of the
education system was that it served
everybody in it but its core constituent
which was the student and so one day I
wrote on the bottom of my email to the
staff I just put it in as a tagline we
put students first and that became the
way in which every decision we get made
gets filtered through it what we do why
we do it when we're gonna do it what we
can charge for it the order in which we
offer it how many different modalities
or languages or devices can it be on all
of those things are if you put the
student first what would the student
want now some people say well if you do
that and they'd all want it for free the
truth is they wouldn't if they didn't
think they could get it for quality for
free so for example there are free
alternatives to check study but they all
prefer to pay for check study because
what we give is not free we give
overwhelming value for the money and so
by putting the student first the choices
that we may become limited the
definition of success becomes clearer
how does this help the student and can
we benefit by doing that the order in
which you do it how much you're willing
to invest and the return on that
investment become much clearer by
putting the customer first and look we
live in a world now where everybody in
the middle is being cut out if possible
so we're living in a much clearer world
of direct-to-consumer if you will so
think about it if you can't satisfy your
customer you don't have a business if
your customers forced to use you it's
easier to disrupt you but if your
customer looks at you and says they know
who I am they understand my problems
they care about me
they give me overwhelming value then you
build a giant motor your competitor so
the best way I can put it is if to quote
or paraphrase I should say Marc
Andreessen software is eating the world
so think about it this way colleges are
a lot like movie theaters you go to the
movie theater you have to wait in a line
or if you get the ticket you get to go
in but you're still going to sit next to
somebody you don't know to watch a movie
you may or may not want to see you're
gonna pay a fortune for popcorn or would
you rather be sitting at home on your
couch watching Netflix what you want to
watch when you want to watch it how you
want to watch it with the people you
want to watch it with at a price you can
afford and college is the same way why
do you want to go to a campus which
takes an hour to get to an hour to get
home to take a single class so that's
half a day when you need money when
you're hungry so so the consequence of
this ultimately has to play out in a
pretty dramatic way there's no sort of
incremental fixes there are things that
colleges are doing that can sustain some
of them for a while they're working with
really good organizations like to you or
companies that allow them to build new
lines of revenue by putting their
graduate schools or specific classes
online but overall if you were to
interview and we have when we've read
the surveys and you can find the surveys
50% of college presidents and their CFOs
feel that their college is on shaky
financial footing just start with that
so the more expensive it gets the more
the fewer kids that can go and so to get
kids to go you got to go create a
discount rate when you create a discount
rate then you're really not getting the
revenue that you need to get into the
school this is really since eighty
percent of college kids will tell you
the primary reason they go to college is
to get a better job then we really have
to involve the employer also so
companies like Chegg we have the
employment data I can predict if you go
to X school takes X classes get X majors
and you're gonna live in Y state I can
predict with a pretty good certainty the
eight companies you're likely to work
for and what you're likely to get paid
and because we've read a hundred million
resumes over 10 years and followed that
pattern to see from our perspective
though we ought to be able to figure out
what skills you want as a person what
skills
benefit you depending on the career path
you're looking to go to so liberal arts
is extraordinarily beneficial for a
subset of people critical thinking
communication all of those things but
modern-day critical thinking a
modern-day decision making a modern-day
communication and rhetoric those are all
things like SEO SEM right they're no
longer you know how to write a speech
and stand up there are different forms
of communications so all that has to
evolve but from from my perspective once
employers are willing to believe that
somebody who's learned these skills from
this place is employable and can be
successful in their environment those
things will change and so today there's
a lot of companies working on it there's
micro degrees if you'd acity there's
Coursera there are college universities
that are doing exclusively online now
they're just doing it under their brand
name this there's going to be a lot of
different ways that people are going to
attempt to do it but at the end of the
day many of the jobs are going to
require some sort of technical
background it doesn't mean you have to
be an engineer in fact the majority of
employees a check or non engineers their
finance people and marketing people and
business people and PR people there's
lots of people and lots of different
kinds of jobs even
companies but everything is utilizing
technology which means you can actually
test for proficiency and so a lot of the
things that we're going to focus on is
whatever level you're at how can we
level you up because if you want to get
better somebody ought to be able to help
you get better and that will help you
both in school and in your career
[Music]